let's go to the basic building blocks of
biology that i think
is another angle at which you can start
to understand the human mind the human
body which is quite fascinating which is
from the basic building blocks start to
simulate start to model
how from those building blocks you can
construct bigger and bigger more complex
systems maybe one day the entirety of
the human biology so
here's another problem that thought to
be impossible to solve which is protein
folding and alpha fold or
specific alpha fold 2
did just that it solved protein folding
i think it's one of the biggest
breakthroughs
certainly in the history of structural
biology but
uh in general in in science
um
maybe from a high level
what is it and how does it work
and then we can ask some fascinating
show questions after sure um so maybe
like to explain it uh to people not
familiar with protein folding is you
know i first of all explain proteins
which is you know proteins are essential
to all life every function in your body
depends on proteins sometimes they're
called the workhorses of biology and if
you look into them and i've you know
obviously as part of alpha fold i've
been researching proteins and and
structural biology for the last few
years you know they're amazing little
bio nano machines proteins they're
incredible if you actually watch little
videos of how they work animations of
how they work
and um proteins are specified by their
genetic sequence called the amino acid
sequence so you can think of it as their
genetic makeup and then in the body uh
in in nature they when they when where
they fold up into a 3d structure so you
can think of it as a string of beads and
then they fold up into a ball now the
key thing is you want to know what that
3d structure is
because the structure the 3d structure
of a protein
is what helps to determine what does it
do the function it does in your body
and also if you're interested in drug
drugs or or disease you need to
understand that 3d structure because if
you want to target something with a drug
compound about to block something the
protein is doing
uh you need to understand where it's
going to bind on the surface of the
protein so obviously in order to do that
you need to understand the 3d structure
so the structure is mapped to the
function the structure's mapped to the
function and the structure is obviously
somehow specified by the by the amino
acid sequence and that's the in essence
the protein folding problem is can you
just from the amino acid sequence the
one-dimensional uh string of letters can
you
immediately computationally predict the
3d structure right and this has been a
grand challenge in biology for over 50
years so i think it was first
articulated by christian anfinsen a
nobel prize winner in 1972 uh as part of
his nobel prize-winning lecture and he
just speculated this should be possible
to go from the amino acid sequence to
the 3d structure we didn't say how so it
i i you know it's been described to me
as equivalent to fermat's last theorem
but for biology right you should as
somebody that very well might win the
nobel prize in the future but outside of
that
you should do more of that kind of thing
in the margins just put random things
that will take like 200 years to solve
set people up for 200 years it should be
possible exactly and just don't give any
interest exactly i think everyone's
exactly should be i'll have to remember
that for future so yeah so he set off
you know with this one throwaway remark
just like fermat you know he he set off
this whole 50-year uh
uh uh field really of computational
biology and and they had you know they
got stuck they hadn't really got very
far with doing this and and um until now
until alpha fall came along this is done
experimentally right very painstakingly
so the rule of thumb is and you have to
like crystallize the protein which is
really difficult some proteins can't be
crystallized like membrane proteins and
then you have to use very expensive
electron microscopes or x-ray
crystallography machines really
painstaking work to get the 3d structure
and visualize the 3d structure so the
rule of thumb in in experimental biology
is that it takes one phd student their
entire phd to do one protein
and with alpha fall 2 we're able to
predict the 3d structure in a matter of
seconds um and so we were you know over
christmas we did the whole human
proteome or every protein in the human
body all 20 000 proteins so the human
protein is like the equivalent of the
human genome but on protein space and uh
and sort of revolutionize really what uh
a structural biologist can do because
now um they don't have to worry about
these painstaking experimentals you know
should they put all of that effort in or
not they can almost just look up the
structure of their proteins like a
google search
and so there's a data set on which it's
trained and how to map this amino acid
sequence first of all it's incredible
that a protein this little chemical
computer is able to do that computation
itself in some kind of distributed way
and do it very quickly that's a weird
thing and they evolved that way because
you know in the beginning
i mean that's a great invention just the
protein itself yes i mean and then they
there's i think probably a history of
like uh they evolved
to have many of these proteins and those
proteins figure out how to be computers
themselves
in such a way that you can create
structures that can interact in complex
ways with each other in order to form
high level functions i mean it's a weird
system that they figured it out well for
sure i mean we you know maybe we should
talk about the origins of life too but
proteins themselves i think are magical
and incredible uh uh uh as i said little
little bio nano machines and um
and and actually levanthal who is
another scientist uh a contemporary of
anfinsen uh he he coined this 11th house
what became known as levantal's paradox
which is exactly what you're saying he
calculated roughly a prote an average
protein which is maybe 2 000 amino acids
bases long is um
is is can fold in maybe 10 to the power
300 different conformations so there's
10 to the power 300 different ways that
protein could fold up and yet somehow in
nature physics solves this solves this
in a matter of milliseconds so proteins
fold up in your body in you know
sometimes in fractions of a second so
physics is somehow solving that search
problem and just to be clear in many of
these cases maybe you can correct me if
i'm wrong there's often a unique way
for that sequence to form itself yes so
among that huge number of possibilities
yes it figures out a way how to
stability
uh in some cases there might be a
misfunction so on which leads to a lot
of the disorders and stuff like that but
yes most of the time it's a unique
mapping and that unique mapping is not
obvious no exactly that's just what the
problem is exactly so there's a unique
mapping usually in a healthy in if it's
healthy and as you say in disease
so for example alzheimer's one one one
conjecture is that it's because of a
misfolded protein a protein that folds
in the wrong way amyloid beta protein so
um and then because it falls in the
wrong way it gets tangled up right in
your in your neurons so
um it's super important to understand
both uh healthy functioning and and also
disease is to understand uh you know
what what these things are doing and how
they're structuring of course the next
step is sometimes proteins change shape
when they interact with something so
they're not just static necessarily in
in biology
maybe you can give some interesting sort
of beautiful things to you about these
early days of alpha fold of of solving
this problem because
unlike games this is
real
physical systems that are less amenable
to
self-play type of mechanisms
the the size of the data set is smaller
than you might otherwise like so you
have to be very clever about certain
things is there something you could
speak to
um
what was very hard to solve and what are
some beautiful aspects about the the
solution yeah i would say alpha fold is
the most complex and also probably most
meaningful system we've built so far so
it's been an amazing time actually in
the last you know two three years to see
that come through because um as we
talked about earlier you know games is
what we started on uh building things
like alphago and alpha zero but really
the ultimate goal was to um not just to
crack games it was just to to to build
use them to bootstrap general learning
systems we could then apply to real
world challenges specifically my passion
is scientific challenges like protein
folding and then alpha fold of course is
our first big proof point of that and so
um you know in terms of the data
and the amount of innovations that had
to go into it we you know it was like
more than 30 different component
algorithms needed to be put together to
crack the protein folding um i think
some of the big innovations were the um
kind of building in some hard coded
constraints around physics and
evolutionary biology um to constrain
sort of things like the bond angles uh
uh in the in the in the protein and
things like that um
a lot but not to impact the learning
system so still allowing the system to
be able to learn the physics uh itself
um from the examples that we had and the
examples as you say there are only about
150 000 proteins even after 40 years of
experimental biology only around 150 000
proteins have been the structures have
been found out about so that was our
training set which is um much less than
normally we would like to use
but using various tricks things like
self-distillation so actually using
alpha folds predictions um some of the
best predictions that it thought was
highly confident in we put them back
into the training set right to make the
training set bigger um that was critical
to to alpha fold working so there was
actually a huge number of different um
innovations like that that were required
to to ultimately crack the problem alpha
fold one what it produced was a
distagram so a kind of a matrix of the
pairwise distances between all of the
molecules in the in the in the protein
and then there had to be a separate
optimization process to
uh
create the 3d structure
and what we did for alpha volt2 is make
it truly end to end so we went straight
from the amino acid sequence of of bases
to
the 3d structure directly without going
through this intermediate step and in
machine learning what we've always found
is that the more end to end you can make
it the better the system and it's
probably because um we you know the in
the end the system's better at learning
what the constraints are than than we
are as the human designers of specifying
it so anytime you can let it flow end to
end and actually just generate what it
is you're really looking for in this
case the 3d structure you're better off
than having this intermediate step which
you then have to hand craft the next
step for so
so it's better to let the gradients and
the learning flow all the way through
the system from the end point the end
output you want to the inputs so that's
a good way to start on a new problem
hand craft a bunch of stuff add a bunch
of manual constraints with a small
intent learning piece or a small
learning piece and grow that learning
piece until it consumes the whole thing
that's right and so you can also see you
know this is a bit of a method we've
developed over doing many sort of
successful outfits we call them alpha x
projects right is and the easiest way to
see that is the evolution of alphago to
alpha zero so alphago was um a learning
system but it was specifically trained
to only play go right so uh and what we
wanted to do and with first version of
alphago is just get to world champion
performance no matter how we did it
right and then and then of course
alphago zero we we we remove the need to
use human games as a starting point
right so it it could just play against
itself from random starting point from
the beginning so that removed the the
need for human knowledge uh about go and
then finally alpha zero then generalized
it so that any things we had in there
the system including things like
symmetry of the go board were removed so
the alpha zero could play from scratch
any two-player game and then mu0 which
is the final
latest version of that set of things was
then extending it so that you didn't
even have to give it the rules of the
game it would learn that for itself so
it could also deal with computer games
as well as board games so that line of
alpha golf goes zero alpha zero mu zero
that's the full trajectory of what you
can take from imitation learning
to full self
supervised learning yeah exactly and
learning learning uh the entire
structure of the environment you put in
from scratch right and and and
bootstrapping it uh through self-play uh
yourself but the thing is it would have
been impossible i think or very hard for
us to build alpha zero or mu0 first out
of the box even psychologically because
you have to
believe in yourself for a very long time
you're constantly dealing with doubt
because a lot of people say that it's
impossible exactly so it was hard enough
just to do go as you were saying
everyone thought that was impossible uh
or at least a decade away um from when
we when we did it back in 2015 24 you
know
and um
and so yes it would have been
psychologically probably very difficult
as well as the fact that of course we
learned a lot by building alphago first
right so it's i think this is why i call
ai in engineering science it's one of
the most fascinating science disciplines
but it's also an engineering science in
the sense that unlike natural sciences
um the phenomenon you're studying it
doesn't exist out in nature you have to
build it first so you have to build the
artifact first and then you can study
how and pull it apart and how it works
you